sich auf ihren der bundestag diskutiert
über die rentenanpassung 2022 und vor
wenigen sekunden ans pult gegangen ist
der zuständige bundesminister
signal der stabilität und
verlässlichkeit davon ausgeht was machen
wir im einzelnen erster diesem renten
paket setzen wir eine kräftige
rentenerhöhung zum ersten juli um das
ist die kräftigste rentenerhöhung seit
vielen jahrzehnten die renten steigen
zum ersten juli in deutschland im westen
um 5,3 prozent und im osten auf 6,1
prozent
meine damen und herren dass es gerade in
diesen zeiten ein wichtiges signal
es folgt der lohn- und
gehaltsentwicklung und ist auch ein
zeichen des stabilität des
arbeitsmarktes
es ist wichtig dass die renten kräftig
in diesem jahr steigen
zweitens wir sorgen aber auch eine
stabilität im system das prinzip der
rentengarantie des nachrufs faktors
sorgt im prinzip dafür dass wir in
krisenzeiten dafür sorgen dass renten
eben nicht gekürzt werden müssen und den
guten zeiten die einen fairen
interessenausgleich zwischen
rentnerinnen und rentnern und
beitragszahlern organisieren und
drittens was mir besonders am herzen
liegt und was endlich erreicht werden
kann ist wir sorgen für deutliche
verbesserungen für erwerbsgeminderte
bürgerinnen und bürger menschen
mit inländischen dem nicht mehr oder nur
eingeschränkt arbeiten können weil sie
beispielsweise an einem krebsleiden oder
an einer schweren nervenerkrankungen
erkrankt sind oder weil sie schwere
behinderungen haben diese menschen zu
unterstützen
meine damen und herren es eine frage der
verantwortung und der gerechtigkeit und
das ist mir ein herzensanliegen dass wir
das endliche dieser koalition
hinbekommen der vorgänger koalition war
das leider noch nicht möglich
lassen sie mich zu den einzelnen punkten
ausführen aber vorweg eins sagen mir ist
aufgefallen als für den gesetzentwurf
veröffentlicht haben gab es
agenturmeldung und agenturmeldungen
müssen immer bebildert werden und
agenturen suchen dann in deutschland
immer stock fotos aus so heißt es um
themen zu bebildern mir ist aufgefallen
dass wenn über rente und rentnerinnen
und rentner
berichtet wird diese stock fotos dann
auf rentnerinnen und rentner zeigen die
entweder auf einer parkbank sitzen und
braungebrannt sind oder bändern und
rentner beim golfen zeigen ich will das
mal ganz grundsätzlich was sagen die
meisten rentnerinnen rentner in
deutschland leben nicht in saus und
braus und ich sage sehr deutlich ich
kenne viele mehr rentnerinnen ränder die
minigolf spielen als welche die sich
golf leisten können und ich will auch
sagen
das wenn rentnerinnen und rentner nach
leben voller arbeit war auf der parkbank
sitzen sie meistens viele jahrzehnte
vorher an der werkbank oder einer
supermarktkasse gearbeitet haben auch
das darf man nicht vergessen deshalb zum
ersten die rentenerhöhung die jetzt zum
ersten juli kommt die es keine gnaden
geschenk des staates das ist ergebnis
von lebensleistung und der tatsache dass
in deutschland die rentenerhöhung der
lohn- und gehaltsentwicklung in dem
arbeitsmarkt folgen und weil wir es
geschafft haben in der kroner pandemie
den deutschen arbeitsmarkt trotz allem
mit kurzarbeit und ähnlichen stabil zu
halten und weil es letztes jahr
ordentliche lohnabschlüsse gaben erst
diese rentenerhöhung von 5,1 prozent im
westen und 6,3 drei 5,3 prozent im
westen und 61 prozent im osten möglich
das würde ich sagen das ist nicht ein
geschenk das es verdient
und zweitens zum thema nachholfaktor und
rentengarantie auch das muss man
erklären dass sie technische begriffe im
kern geht es darum dass wir im jahre
2020 am beginn der pandemie einen
wirtschaftlichen einbruch erlebt haben
auch ein einbruch bei den löhnen der
dazu geführt hätte dass statistisch ein
jahr später
2021 die renten hätten gekürzt werden
müssen aus guten gründen machen wir das
in deutschland nicht und das ganze nennt
sich rentengarantie das ist die eine
seite der medaille die andere seite der
medaille ist dass in zeiten ins besser
läuft wir dann eben einen fairen
interessenausgleich zwischen
rentnerinnen und rentnern
beitragszahlern leisten auch das
stabilisiert das system und ich glaube
es ist eine frage der verlässlichkeit
und drittens zu der erwerbsgemindert
meine damen und herren wir haben es in
den letzten jahren seit 2014 geschafft
bei den erwerbsminderungsrenten zu
verbesserungen zu kommen schritt für
schritt unter meiner amtsvorgängerin
andrea nahles auch in meiner letzten
legislaturperiode als
bundesarbeitsminister in der großen
koalition allerdings nur für zukünftige
fälle und die meisten schreiben als
abgeordnete haben wir immer bekommen von
erwerbsgeminderten die schule bestand
sind die arbeiten wollten aber die
erkrankt sind die in der arbeits leben
zum teil verunfallt sind die einfach
wollten aber nicht mehr konnten und ich
bin froh dass wir jetzt zu drei
millionen erwerbsgeminderte in
deutschland zu deutlichen verbesserungen
kommen die damen und herren das zeigt
auch die leistungsfähigkeit der
solidarität der gesetzlichen
rentenversicherung
diese drei schritte sind wichtig und ich
weiß was nachher der debatte passieren
wird es wird welche geben die sagen ist
alles schön gut aber wir haben im moment
massive preissteigerungen und richtig
wir verkennen überhaupt nicht welche
sorgen sich viele bürgerinnen und bürger
auch wenn rentner in deutschland machen
und dann wird es einige aus der
opposition geben die wiederum die
gestern behaupten im entlastungspaket
den 30 milliarden die die koalition auf
den weg gebracht hat sei nichts drin für
rentnerinnen und rentner da sage ich
sehr deutlich das ist falsch ich finde
sie sollten richtig sein
weil der kollege straubinger sie es
besser wissen ich will es ihnen mal ganz
deutlich sagen erstens profitieren
natürlich auch rentnerinnen und rentnern
von den allgemeinen entlastung wie der
abschaffung der eeg umlage
zweitens profitieren rentnerinnen und
rentner natürlich auch davon dass für
kraftstoff preise senken und mit den
neuen euro ticket ermöglichen dass
mobilität bezahlbar bleibt drittens wird
auch der grundfreibetrag erhöht auch das
ist etwas von dem rentnerinnen und
rentner profitieren können und natürlich
ist es auch so dass sie den
grundsicherungssystem mit dem 200 euro
zuschlag auch menschen der
grundsicherung im alter profitieren
genauso übrigens meine damen und herren
von der tatsache dass sie mit dem
heizkostenzuschuss für wohngeldempfänger
innen und renten erreichen also wir
können gerne mit mir darüber streiten ob
es genug ist aber dass nichts zur
anderen renten an diesen paketen ist
stimmlich und sie sollten das auch so
einmal damit herren bei diesen renten
paket 1 sorgen wir für stabilität und
verlässlichkeit und mit den entlastungs
paketen machen wir in schwierigen zeiten
das leben für viele menschen ein stück
einfacher will an dieser stelle aber
auch sagen nicht nur für rentnerinnen
und rentner falls und wenn die
preissteigerung ganz lange dauern werden
dann werden wir auch weitere maßnahmen
ergreifen auch für rentnerinnen und
rentner dann geht es aber nicht um
einmalige maßnahmen dann muss es um
strukturelle entlastung geben gerade für
mittlere und reinfinden
das ganze ist notwendig und ich sage das
deshalb weil wir unsere gesellschaft in
diesen schwierigen zeiten zusammenhalten
müssen und deshalb ist die ansage dieser
koalition ganz ganz klar wir werden
dafür sorgen dass unser sozialstaat
funktioniert wir werden nicht zulassen
dass äußere sicherheit gegen sozialen
frieden im inland ausgespielt wird so
richtig es ist dass wir die bundeswehr
besser ausrüsten es wird nicht zulasten
der sozialen sicherheit in deutschland
geben das ist die klare ansage dieser
koalition herzlichen dank
die bundesminister hubertus heil hat
erläutert was seiner meinung nach den
rentnerinnen und rentner gutes
widerfahren soll ab 20 22 rund 21
millionen sollen profitieren von der
rentenanpassung
2022 und auch die erwerbsminderungsrente
sind ja im blick bei diesem
gesetzentwurf der erste redner aus der
opposition max straubinger
der bundesregierung zur rentenanpassung
und zur verbesserung der eu dienten also
der erwerbsunfähigkeitsrente und ich
möchte beginnen mit einem zeitlosen satz
der letztendlich zum ausdruck bringt
nämlich die verantwortung der union für
die rentenpolitik nämlich aber eins ist
sicher die rente wie es norbert blüm mal
plakatiert hat verehrte damen und herren
und da hat er recht gehabt da hat er
recht gehabt und die union die habe sich
immer an diesen satz orientiert und wenn
der bundesminister ist dargelegt hat
dass hier die renten zum ersten juli
steigen werden um 5 35 prozent in west-
und in um 6.12 im osten so ist dies mit
ein ausdruck nämlich der vergangenheit
und dementsprechend der vergangenen
bundesregierung die dafür die grundlagen
gelegt hat nämlich unter angela merkel
unter führenden lohn als rhythmus
verliert deutlich sagen was sie als
bundesminister hier dies natürlich auch
mit zu verantworten haben herr kollege
teil der bundesminister halten völlig
mit klar da stehen wir auch mit dazu
aber wenn wir heute darstellen können
dass es kräftige rentensteigerungen gibt
so muss man schon darauf verweisen dass
es letztes jahr keine rentensteigerung
aus bekannten gründen auch des
wirtschaftlichen einbruchs der mit zu
verzeichnen war und dass dies auch mit
nachgeholt wird jetzt auch in dieser
kräftig kite aber das bedeutet ganz
besonders herr bundesminister und sie
haben wir ausführlich noch über das
entlastungspaket ob der
energiepreisentwicklung wird darauf
hingewiesen dass auch die rentnerinnen
und rentner daran teilhaben sollten hier
mit in deutschland unter geht es eben um
die 300 euro für die
energiepreissteigerungen und die
und dies halten sie den rentnerinnen und
rentnern fuhr und so geht es nicht und
wir als union wir werden darauf drängen
auch in den beratungen das hier
weiterhin auch die rentnerinnen und
rentner genauso mit entlastet werden es
wies die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer auch werden es gibt doch
gar keinen sinn der bundesminister und
ich plädiere an jedes soziale
verantwortung nämlich gut verdienen die
arbeitnehmer in der automobilindustrie
zum beispiel 300 euro also mit einer
unterstützung zu geben und den armen
rentnern der möglicherweise keine
betriebliche altersversorgung und gar
nichts hat den herbert es nicht mit also
wo ist ihre sozialpolitische
verantwortung
kabinettsminister und ich würden sie
auch dann auffordern sich die wenn sie
es von uns von der union nicht machen
sondern zumindest dann von ihren ja auch
mit in der partei verankerten kranken
also zumindest die mahnenden worte von
verena bentele oder der usa damals
staatssekretärin bei der spd
bundestagfraktion war hier dies mit
aufzunehmen diese mahnenden worten
themen sprechen die rentnerinnen und
rentner zu unterstützen wir als union
sind dazu bereit
und das zweite ist
oben zu recht auch die verbesserungen
bei der erwerbsminderungsrente
die erwerbsminderungsrente ist ein
wichtiger sozialpolitischer baustein mit
in unserem rentensystem das gilt es aber
dann schon zu hinterfragen warum wir nur
die erwerbsminderungsrentner beginnend
vom ersten januar 2001 bis 2018 mit
einem pauschalen zuschlag beglücken denn
es gab auch vor
2001 erwerbsminderungsrentner die sogar
die sogar die sogar weniger
zurechnungszeiten damals hat nämlich nur
bis zum bis 55 jahren also das bedeutet
dass sie hier letztendlich
rentenpolitischen nachholen müssen also
diese frage die muss auch mit gelöst
werden und wie sie dann darauf kommen
dass die einen 7,5 prozent zuschlag
bekommen und die anderen 4,5 prozent
also das hat sich mir noch nicht
erschlossen das sollten sie hier meines
erachtens auch mit algen wird
fertig kolleginnen und kollegen spd und
auch der regierungsfraktionen es ist
auch richtig dass dann auch als akteur
wieder eingeführt wird also hier hat er
die fdp darauf gedrungen das ist auch
richtig denn wenn die
arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmer weniger
einkommen haben da muss sich dies leider
auch deinen rentnerinnen rentnern hier
natürlich mit niederschlagen in der
gesetzgebung aber dann muss man es auch
richtig machen wir stehen dafür dass es
sicherlich mit hier keine erniedrigung
der renten gibt es ist überhaupt ja
völlig klar aber dann muss es auch
nachgeholt werden während die
kolleginnen und kollegen der fdp dass
sie sich zurücklehnen und sagen wir
haben es ist schon in ordnung nur weil
es im heutigen jahr klappt aber in
zukünftigen jahren wird ihr
nachholfaktor sowie der im gesetz steht
keine wirkung erzielen das ist mutig er
mit dieser situation da bin ich schon
erstaunt darüber also das heißt wir
werden noch in den beratungen darauf
intensiv mit eingehen und darauf freue
ich mich herzlicher dank
max straubinger für die unionsfraktion
um genauer zu sein für die csu aus der
csu-landesgruppe hat wieder dorf für die
eingangsrede des bundesministers für
arbeit und soziales für die fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen jetzt markus kurth
in deren sozialpolitik und
rentenexperten und kollegen sehr
geehrter herr straubinger wenn ich in
der letzten zeit so die reden der union
zum thema sozial und arbeitsmarktpolitik
höre habe ich irgendwie gemischte
gefühle einerseits freue ich mich ja
dass sie nicht irgendwie jetzt
haarscharf den neoliberalen kurs
einschlagen oder wirtschaftsliberalen
sondern tatsächlich sich zu den
prinzipien unseres sozialstaats auch
bekennen und in dem rahmen argumentieren
auf der anderen seite muss ich mich doch
sehr wundern wie sie jetzt hier quasi
uns links überholen wollen von der ampel
und zusätzliche leistungsausweitungen
fordern die sie alle blockiert haben
doch in den letzten 16 jahren
also zum beispiel
wer hat sie denn wer hat sie denn daran
gehindert das was wir hier in erster
lesung heute ein bringen nämlich
verbesserungen bei der
erwerbsminderungsrente im bestand diese
auch vorzunehmen
also ich will dabei gar nicht ich will
dich in abrede stellen dass
sie für neue rentnerinnen und rentner
insgesamt in drei stufen in den letzten
acht jahren verbesserungen in der
erwerbsminderungsrente vorgenommen haben
das team haben wir damals auch
zugestimmt aber für die bestands
rentnerinnen und bestandsrentner ist
nichts rausgekommen und das holen wir
jetzt hier als ampel koalition nach
und
natürlich kann man jetzt sagen das ist
noch nicht genug die verbesserungen die
damals die neue rentner zutritts rentner
bekommen haben die müssten da noch etwas
höher sein dafür haben wir ja ein
parlamentarisches verfahren
da können wir dann darüber diskutieren
und ich bin auch der auffassung dass wir
hier nochmal etwas verbessern sollten
und das
ist nicht nur geboten sozusagen aus
sozialer verantwortung
sondern diese stärkung einer elementaren
absicherungen in unserem sozialsystem
hat auch etwas mit stabilisierung der
wirtschaft zu tun und da gehe ich mal
zurück zu den anfängen der
rentenversicherung ins jahr
1889 da ist als erster baustein die
sogenannte invalidenrente also die
heutige erwerbsminderungsrente
eingeführt worden und zwar nicht als
gnadenakt gegenüber beschäftigten
sondern weil es eine voraussetzung für
das abhängige beschäftigungsverhältnisse
für die durchsetzung des modernen
kapitalismus war
1889 mein wahlkreis ist im ruhrgebiet
entstand dieses große industriegebiet
die arbeitskräfte mussten aus masuren
dem heutigen polen angeworben werden und
welche veranlassung hätten diese gehabt
fern ihrer familie und jeder absicherung
in dieses dunkle loch zu steigen wo
einem jederzeit ein schwerer kohle
brocken oder einstein das bein
zertrümmern konnte welche veranlassung
hätten burschen vom lande gehabt in
stahlwerke zu gehen mit offenen ländern
wo einmal schnell der arm abgerissen
werden konnte die haben das unter
anderem auch nur deswegen gemacht und
die arbeitgeber und die industriellen
mussten wir auch was anbieten weil es
eine absicherung gab für diesen fall der
damals gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich war
insofern ist soziale sicherung jetzt
nicht irgendetwas was man sich mal auch
leisten oder finanzieren muss sondern es
ist die kehrseite der wirtschaftlichen
verwertung der menschlichen arbeitskraft
ich will dich auf diesen grundsätzlichen
zusammenhang war aufmerksam macht
freue mich diesen fall mich in diesen
debatten um sozialpolitik häufig stört
das dann lohnnebenkosten als belastung
gesehen werden und als bürde und das
muss man doch erstmal erwirtschaften
hindernis der wirtschaft nein nein nein
es ist so dass beides zusammengehört und
beides voraussetzung dafür ist dass
unsere volkswirtschaft funktioniert
und im übrigen
wird das auch gespiegelt wenn uns
delegationen aus sogenannten
schwellenländer oder schon nicht mehr
nur schwellenländern industrieländern
uns besuchen es ist ja auch häufiger mal
der fall dass aus china indonesien kann
ich mich erinnern anderen ländern auch
parlamentarier kommen um hier sich
anzugucken wie läuft unser sozialsystem
und das was sie einhellig sagen ist für
unsere weitere wirtschaftliche
entwicklung
brauchen wir eine sozialversicherung und
zwar aus volkswirtschaftlichen gründen
denn was tun leute beispielsweise in
china die sich sozusagen so in den
mittelstandsbereich
hoch gearbeitet haben was tun die wenn
es keine krankenversicherung keine
rentenversicherung gibt sie sparen sie
sparen wie die irren und darum ist die
sparquote in china riesen hoch es gibt
diesen grauen kapitalmarkt es gibt halbe
millionen städte mit leer stehenden
wohnungen die die leute besitzen als
altersvorsorge es gibt also schwerste
volkswirtschaftliche unwuchten und ein
nicht vorhandenes sozialsystem ist ein
wirtschaftliches hemmnis david ein schuh
draus und das finde ich sollten auch
gerade diejenigen die von der
arbeitgeberseite und die die meinen sie
politisch repräsentieren
das sollten die dummheit sich
gegenwärtigen dass wir hier zu einem
positiven volkswirtschaftlichen ansatz
kommen und die ampel wird in diesem
sinne in diesem bewusstsein und dieser
verantwortung jetzt diese
erwerbsminderungsrente weiterentwickeln
und auch noch eine menge weitere renten
paket auf den weg in vielen dank
markus kurth waren das für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen in dieser debatte
in dieser ersten debatte zur
rentenanpassung
2022 es soll ja mehr geld geben für 21
millionen rentnerinnen und rentner in
deutschland dazu jetzt ulrike schulte
ziesing aus der fdp fraktion
der bürger mit dem heute zu debattieren
den gesetzesentwurf arbeitet minister
heil eine liste ab die erste aufgaben
aus dem koalitionsvertrag enthält
außerdem die jährliche rentenanpassung
es soll eine rentenanpassung von 5,3
prozent west beziehungsweise
6,12 prozent ost beschlossen werden so
kann schon die frage aufkommen ist
angesichts einer derartigen
wirtschaftlichen krise in der wir uns im
moment befinden eine rentenerhöhung in
diesem umfang angemessen ich sage ja
weil die renten in deutschland ohnehin
viel zu niedrig sind und weil die
rentner von der galoppierenden inflation
der lebenshaltungskosten genauso und zum
teil sogar stärker betroffen sind als
andere
wir als fdp halten ist deshalb für einen
fehler dass die rentner nicht in das
entlastungspaket der bundesregierung mit
einbezogen werden minister heil und da
habe ich eben eine andere auffassung als
sie in meinem heimatland mecklenburg
vorpommern leben die menschen mit den
niedrigsten renten bundesweit wer auf
grundsicherung im alter angewiesen ist
bekommt immerhin eine 200 euro
einmalzahlung auch das reicht nicht lang
aber die mehrheit die ganz knapp über
dieser grenze liegt die geht leer aus
das ist nicht in ordnung und nicht
gerecht
ich rate deshalb dringend dazu das noch
einmal zu überdenken um diese
gerechtigkeitslücke zu schließen worüber
ich mich heute freue die geplanten
verbesserungen im bereich der
erwerbsminderungsrente dieses mal
endlich für die bestandsrentner rund 15
prozent aller erwerbsminderungsrentner
sind gleichzeitig auf grundsicherung
angewiesen keine gruppe hat ein größeres
armutsrisiko
kein wunder nach dem kahlschlag von 2001
um mehr als 10 prozent sanken die
erwerbsunfähigkeitsrente jahr für jahr
weiter ins bodenlose deshalb war es auch
zu keinem zeitpunkt zu verstehen dass
die notwendigen korrekturen von 2014 und
2018 jeweils nur für die neuzugänge aber
eben nicht für die bestandsrentner
beschlossen wurden wir als fdp haben das
immer bemängelt und dass das nun behoben
werden soll ist aus unserer sicht ein
längst überfälliger schritt allerdings
ein schritt auf den rentner noch bis
juli 2024 warten müssen man könnte jetzt
auf die idee kommen dass hier politik
nach kassenlage betrieben wird es wäre
ja nicht das erste mal nur so erklärt
sich zum beispiel die benachteiligung
der mütter deren kinder vor 1992
geworden sind nur so erklärt sich die
unterschiedliche behandlung von
betriebsrenten was die doppel vorbei
tragung betrifft nur so erklärt sich
dass es den härtefallfonds für die in
der ddr geschiedenen frauen immer noch
nicht gibt oder für die berufsgruppen
die bei der rentenüberleitung des rost
gefallen sind das heißt so oft setzt
sich die politik erst in bewegung wenn
sie muss das ergebnis ist ein wust an
regelungen die niemand mehr durchschaut
und die unter gerechtigkeit aspekten
äußerst fragwürdig sind ich weiß nicht
ob es ein trost ist wenigstens die
stichtagsregelung für die einführung der
zuschläge für die erwerbsminderungsrente
lässt sich rein sachlich erklären denn
die nächsten zwei jahre stehen bei der
gesetzlichen rentenversicherung komplett
im zeichen dass werden über leitungs
abschluss gesetzes und der grundrente
für mehr gibt es weder technische noch
personelle kapazitäten liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen wenn eine ganze behörde auf
jahre blockiert ist so dass neue gesetze
sozusagen in warteschleife produziert
werden müssen dann läuft etwas falsch
entweder bei der gesetzgebung oder bei
der ausstattung der behörde auch hier
ist die regierung gefordert anspruch und
wirklichkeit zu überprüfen und
entsprechend zu handeln
im falle der erwerbsminderungsrentner
die noch so lange auf unterstützung
warten müssen könnte das so aussehen
dass hier eine komplette nachzahlung der
zuschläge für das verlorene jahr erfolgt
darüber diskutiere ich gerne mit ihnen
im ausschuss für arbeit und soziales die
als afd werden uns einer
leistungsverbesserung für rentner
jedenfalls nicht verweigern und auch
einen entsprechenden gesetzesentwurf
unterstützen vielen dank
[Applaus]
ulrike ziesing für und aus der afg
fraktion in der debatte über die
rentenanpassung 20
22 und in dieser debatte wird die
nächste rednerin sein anja schulz aus
der fdp-fraktion
[Applaus]
präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren ich halte den vorliegenden
gesetzesentwurf für einen erfolg damit
seinen drei hauptelemente der erhöhung
der renten der reaktivierung des nachhol
verstoß und der verbesserung der
erwerbsminderungsrente im bestand karin
vor einem einzelnen fair gegenüber den
rentnerinnen und rentnern die uns durch
ihre arbeit in den letzten jahrzehnten
dahin gebracht haben wo wir heute
wirtschaftlich stehen fair gegenüber den
erwerbsminderung denjenigen
erwerbsminderungsrente beziehen denn
unsere solidarische gesellschaft steht
für jene ein die aus eigener kraft ihren
beitrag nicht mehr voll oder nur noch
teilweise leisten können und fair auch
gegenüber den kommenden generationen
dennoch ihre belange werden mit der
rentenanpassungsformel wieder besser
berücksichtigt
die reaktivierung des nachholfaktor es
führt dazu dass rentenpolitik nicht nur
für heutige rentner gemacht wird sondern
auch für deren enkelkinder was die
ältere generation besser stellt darf der
jüngeren später nicht auf die füße
fallen und wer jetzt behauptet dass
aktuell nicht der richtige zeitpunkt
dafür sein und davon gebrauch zu machen
der hat nicht verstanden dass man
generationengerechtigkeit nicht einfach
aussetzen kann
es kann nämlich nicht sein dass wir uns
mit dem thema erst beschäftigen wenn es
uns in den kram passt probleme die man
vor sich hin schiebt aus denen wir jetzt
gerade an anderen stellen die fliegen
einen irgendwann um die ohren
maßnahmen wie diese haben aber auch viel
mit aufklärungsarbeit zu tun ich musste
einige artikel und meinungen lesen in
denen der nachholfaktor als eine art
diebstahl an den heutigen rentnerinnen
und rentern dargestellt wird eine
maßnahme die so informiert wird kann
willkommen auf verständnis stoßen ich
mache die wirkung einmal deutlich die
renten steigen mit den löhnen sie fallen
aber nicht mit ihnen dafür sorgt direkt
garantieren ist auch gut so diese
ausgebliebene kürze muss allerdings
irgendwann mal wieder nachgeholt werden
damit die renten den löhnen nicht
davonlaufen so weit so logisch der
nachholfaktor ist also ein nachhaltiger
beitrag für die finanzierbarkeit unseres
systems
die vorherige aussetzung war eine
ungerechte manipulation
rentenanpassungsformel zulasten der
jüngeren generation
solche ungerechtigkeiten sollten wir aus
der welt schaffen und wir müssen endlich
aufhören die debatten um den willen ist
allen recht zu machen immer auf dem
rücken der jungen generation
auszufechten
denn trotz der einführung des
nachholfaktor können sich die 21
millionen rentnerinnen und rentner in
unserem land auch ein üppiges rentenplus
freuen im westen ist es sogar das größte
in den letzten 40 jahren jetzt wo mit
blick auf den kassenzettel auffällt dass
wir in schwierigen zeiten leben ist
diese erhöhung auch besonders notwendig
doch notwendigkeiten gibt es in der
rentenpolitik sehr viele ein problem das
steht schon sehr lange im raum dass
durch viele ansätze bisher noch nicht
geklärt werden konnte die geplante
verbesserung der erwerbsminderungsrente
im bestand ist eine enorme erleichterung
für eine gruppe die in unserer
gesellschaft leider nur eine sehr
geringe lobby hat sie erhält pauschalen
zuschlag wir freuen uns dass es für alle
ampel tat eine selbstverständlichkeit
war diese vernachlässigung endlich
anzugehen damit stellen wir drei mio
erwerbsminderungsrente rinnen und brennt
nach und auch jene die inzwischen in
altersrente sind in der zukunft besser
und zukunft das ist auch ein wichtiges
stichwort mit dem ich schließen möchte
zukunft unsere rentenversicherung ist an
viele stabilisierenden maßnahmen
geknüpft der nachholfaktor leistet dabei
einen beitrag
es muss aber noch mehr kommen die
kapitaldeckung ist dafür das beste
konzept seit langem unsere demokratie
arbeitet gegen unser rentensystem
also müssen wir uns schritt für schritt
unabhängiger von ihr machen lassen wir
die zukünftigen rentnerinnen und rentner
haben produktivkapital teilhaben und
zeigen wir auch der jungen generation
dass sie sich auf im rentensystem auch
in zukunft verlassen kann
anja schulz für die fdp fraktion und
damit auch für die
koalitionsfraktionen zur rentenanpassung
20 22 die altersbezüge sollen steigen
zum ersten juli um 5,35 prozent im osten
auf 6,12 prozent nächster redner dazu
ist matthias birkwald rentenpolitischer
sprecher der linksfraktion sie den
menschen die wegen einer chronischen
krankheit zwischen 2001 und 2008 10 in
eine erwerbsminderungsrente gehen
mussten ihre renten zu verbessern das
ist gut das haben wir linken seit langem
gefordert für uns linke ist klar
krankheit darf nicht arm machen dafür
sind ihre zuschläge von 75 und 4,5
prozent mehr erwerb
erwerbsminderungsrente aber viel zu
niedrig bei einer durchschnittlichen
rente von aktuell nur
886 euro während das zwar immerhin gut
66 bzw fast 40 euro mehr netto im monat
aber diesen zuschlag wollen sie
frühestens in zwei jahren ab dem ersten
juli 20 24 auszahlen dass meine damen
und herren ist völlig inakzeptabel
die betroffene müssen seit 2014 ertragen
dass ihre von viel zu hohen abschlägen
und viel zu kurzen zurechnungszeiten
betroffenen armutsrenten nicht
verbessert wurden liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der koalition lieber hubertus
heil sie möchten die viel zu lange
vergessenen menschen nun ein weiteres
mal mehr als zwei jahre im regen stehen
lassen dazu sage ich ihnen das geht gar
nicht
ich habe ja verständnis für die probleme
der rentenversicherung aber wenn es
wirklich nicht schneller gehen sollte
dann müssen den betroffenen im jahr 20
24 wenigstens die zuschläge für die
verlorenen zwei jahre rückwirkend
erstattet werden das fordert der
deutsche gewerkschaftsbund das fordern
alle sozialverbände das fordern wir
linken und darum werden wir dazu einen
entsprechenden änderungsantrag
einbringen aber damit nicht genug sie
erwecken den eindruck mit den zuschlägen
würden sie diejenigen die zwischen 2001
und 2008 10 in eine
erwerbsminderungsrente
gegangen sind mit jenen gleichstellen
die seit 2009 10 von den besseren
zurechnungszeiten profitieren dieser
eindruck ist falsch für eine echte
gleichstellung müssten die zuschläge
fast auf acht und auf 13 prozent
verdoppelt werden das hat ihnen der
sozialverband deutschland präzise
vorgerechnet aber in ihrem gesetzentwurf
heißt es dass es den zuschlag nur bis zu
einem zitat finanzvolumen von 2,6
milliarden euro zitat ende geben soll ja
wo haben sie denn diese zahl mehr mir
scheint die wurde von finanzminister
lindner ausgewürfelt denn diese zahl ist
völlig willkürlich und vor allem sie ist
viel zu niedrig
sie wollen
18 jährige abend euro für eine obskure
aktien rente ausgeben aber chronisch
kranke namens rentnerinnen und rentern
knapp die hälfte des notwendigen
zuschlages verweigern die hier wollen
sie dennoch bei den ärmsten rentner
gruppen einsparen nein das ist das
gegenteil von sozialer gerechtigkeit und
das ist nur noch zum kopfschütteln auch
deshalb
werden wir einen durchgerechneten
änderungsantrag einbringen und auch für
diesen wird die linke als stimme der
sozialen gerechtigkeit die unterstützung
der sozialverbände erhalten dessen bin
ich mir sicher verehrte bundesregierung
auf druck der fdp führen sie den zurecht
ausgesetzten nachholfaktor wieder ein
damit kürzen sie die diesjährige im
vergleich zwar sehr hohe rentenerhöhung
aber angesichts einer inflation von bis
zu sieben prozent viel zu niedrige
renten erhöhung um 0,6 prozentpunkte und
das ist schlecht
lieber robert detail dass sich die
rentnerinnen und rentner im juli über
mindestens 5,35 prozent mehr rente
freuen dürfen ist bei diesem gegenwind
der fdp wirklich eine große leistung
chapeau aber nach ihrem gesetzentwurf
wird die rentenanpassung 20 23 in der
heißen inflationsphase von ursprünglich
5,4 auf 2,9 prozent gekürzt werden und
damit die kaufkraft der renten inmitten
einer energiepreis krise auch dem
kommenden jahr entwerten das darf nicht
passieren und deshalb sage ich die
aktuelle ausbezahlte durchschnittsrente
alle 21,2 millionen rentnerinnen und
rentner liegt nur bei 1089 euro vor
steuern das heißt die rentnerinnen und
rentner brauchen jeden cent die rente
muss zum leben reichen bessern sie
diesen gesetzentwurf nach herzlichen
dank
fordert der rentenpolitische sprecher
der linksfraktion matthias birkwald
und wir werden hören was dazu sagt
michael gerdes aus der spd fraktion
auch präsidentin meine damen und herren
dass das gesetzesvorhaben dass wir heute
beraten wird von vielen menschen seit
langem herbeigesehnt auch von mir und
wir beschließen mit dem vorliegenden
gesetzesentwurf nicht nur die
rentenanpassung sondern auch
verbesserungen für sogenannte
rentnerinnen und rentner im
erwerbsminderungsrente bestand also von
menschen die von anfang 2001 bis 2008
zehn erwerbsminderungsrente bezogen
haben oder in erwerbsminderungsrente
gegangen sind und die bislang wenig von
den verbesserungen aus den jahren 2014
und 2019 gespürt haben sie sind zum teil
mit erheblichen abschlägen in rente
gegangen und deswegen ist es wichtig
dass wir neben den verbesserungen die
wir für die neue rentnerinnen und
rentnern gemacht haben jetzt auch an die
bestandsrentner rangehen und den auch
etwas zukommen lassen wir korrigieren
jetzt eine gerechtigkeitslücke wir uns
seit jahren umtreibt und die für viele
betroffene nicht nachvollziehbar war und
es bis heute nicht ist liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen erwerbsminderungsrenten
werden nicht freiwillig in anspruch
genommen sie werden dann beantragt wenn
jemand wegen einer krankheit oder eines
unfalls ausscheidet und das vorzeitig
aus seinem berufsleben und nur unter
großen einschränkungen weiter arbeiten
kann und genau diese menschen brauchen
unseren besonderen schutz und unsere
solidarität die solidarität der
versichertengemeinschaft
insofern sind die geplante zuschläge
mehr als berechtigt und es ist auch
berechtigt das ebenso menschen mit
alters- und hinterbliebenenrente diese
zuschläge erhalten wenn sie eine
erwerbsminderungsrente im dafür
vorgesehenen zeitraum bezogen haben und
die erhöhung für knapp drei millionen
menschen über die wir heute reden ist
eine vereinbarung aus dem
koalitionsvertrag
und ist richtig dass wir dieses vorhaben
zügig als eines der ersten umsätzen
allerdings das muss ich auch sagen gibt
es noch einige wermutstropfen dabei etwa
die auszahlung des zuschlags erst zum
ersten juli 2014 das trübt die freude
und schmerz mich persönlich auch das
kann ich ihnen versichern aber
die umsetzung muss auch machbar sein und
von der rentenversicherung zuverlässig
und fehlerfrei nach getesteten verfahren
realisiert werden können sowohl wenn es
um das verfahren einzelner bearbeitungen
geht als auch um die programmierung von
daten
nichtsdestotrotz werde ich mich wie die
spd sich dafür einsetzen dass wir den
späten beginn noch einmal überdenken und
einen ausgleich finden das werden wir im
parlamentarischen verfahrens sicherlich
noch diskutieren einen anderen punkt
dagegen kann nicht vorbehaltlos
unterstützen und das meine damen und
herren ist die automatische auszahlung
wir wollen den teilweise betagten
betroffenen keine komplizierten
antragsverfahren mehr zumuten und dabei
profitieren wir aktuell von den guten
erfahrungen bei der grundrente mein
herzlicher dank geht an dieser stelle an
das bundesarbeitsministerium und diesen
dank finde ich muss man auch mal
aussprechen
auch anträge zu verzichten es gibt nur
eine frage des respekts vor den menschen
es ist auch ein schutz vor zu viel
bürokratie und vor allem ist es sozial
gerecht denn wir wissen wir nicht wir
können alle
die situation einer
erwerbsminderungsrente komm wir sprechen
heute jedoch nicht nur über die
verbesserung für
erwerbsminderungsrentner rinnen und
rentner sondern auch über ein üppiges
rentenplus ab juli dieses jahres und
meine damen und herren wir stehen vor
einer ungewöhnlich hohen rentenanpassung
der höchsten seit fast 40 jahren und das
ist schon etwas 5 35 prozent erhöhung in
westdeutschland und 6,25 prozent in den
neuen bundesländern oft gesagt hier aber
immer wieder gerne noch mal betont das
ist im übrigen auch mehr als ein
einmaliger zuschuss bei der energie
beihilfe und ende november kurz nach
koalitionsverhandlungen lieber herr
bundesminister roberto sein haben sie
selbst noch nichtmals gewagt von solchen
zahlen zu sprechen umso höher müssen wir
jetzt die kräftige anhebung der renten
für 21 millionen rentnerinnen und
rentner einschätzen zumal in einer zeit
in der diese erhöhung angesichts von
inflation und internationalen krisen
dringend gebraucht wird und dabei
berüchtigten wir auch den nachholfaktor
die höhe der rennens war damit aber für
einen ausgleich zwischen löhnen und
renten sorgt und die renten folgen den
löhnen das haben wir auch schon gehört
und dieses prinzip haben wir 20 21 von
aufgrund von corona nicht eingehalten
und trotz ist man dem ibe linken
einbruchs der einnahmen ich erinnere in
diesem zusammenhang an die kurzarbeit
übrigens ein gutes instrument haben wir
im letzten jahr keine rentenkürzung
durchgeführt und dafür hat die
rentengarantie gesorgt eine garantie die
sich für viele rentnerinnen rentner als
wichtiger anker erwiesen hat die
rentengarantie war in der korona krise
das richtige signal
dass renten hand kostet in der werks
minderungsrecht in bestands
verbesserungs gesetz wäre ich ein wort
ist jetzt weitere verbesserung
vorausgesetzt das richtige signal besser
meine damen und herren wäre es aber wenn
es gar nicht erst dazu käme dass
menschen erwerbsminderung beziehen durch
mehr und bessere
rehabilitation können menschen länger
gesund am arbeitsmarkt bleiben und
lassen sie uns auch daran arbeiten
herzlichen dank
michael gerdes aus und für die spd
fraktion zur rentenanpassung
2022 die stärkste rentenerhöhung seit
1994 betonte die bundesregierung und ein
zusätzlicher zuschlag für drei millionen
bezieher von erwerbsminderungsrenten
nächster redner kita kraus der
unionsfraktion
kolleginnen und kollegen lassen sie mich
noch einmal bitten das protokoll
festhalten dass wir als union uns über
die erhöhung der renten ausdrücklich
freuen wir freuen uns deshalb darüber
weil es zeigt dass wir letztes jahr eine
gute wirtschaftliche entwicklung haben
und dafür war auch die union
verantwortlich und herr kurt ich wunder
mich da schon dass sie zweifel haben
konnten dass wir jetzt einen nicht auf
dem sozialpolitischen kurs bleiben ich
kann ihnen nur sagen wer hat's erfunden
das waren wir mit der sozialen
marktwirtschaft
und wir freuen uns auch über die
verbesserungen bei der
erwerbsminderungsrente auch dafür haben
wir lange gekämpft und herr minister wir
hätten uns auch schon sehr gefreut wenn
es in der letzten legislaturperiode dazu
einen vorschlag vorgelegt hätten wir
haben das immer gefordert und sie hätten
und ich glaube mit uns hätten sich 20
millionen rentnerinnen und rentner heute
noch mehr gefordert gefreut wenn sie ein
zusätzliches entlastungspaket für die
rentnerinnen und rentner präsentiert
hätten denn es ist nicht verständlich
warum jemand der gutes geld verdient in
diesem land 300 euro zusätzliches
energie geld bekommt während der
durchschnittsrentner mit 1300 euro rente
leer ausgeht das ist die ungerechtigkeit
ist sie hier machen
es nun noch mal der blick auf die
details ich habe eben gesagt
erwerbsminderungsrente wird verbessert
7,5 und 4,5 prozent zuschlag aber da
gebe ich dem kollegen birkwald recht die
zahlen sind nicht wirklich hergeleitet
und dann hatte ich auch erst in verdacht
dass es vielleicht an christian lindner
im finanzministerium liegen könnte und
dann ist mir aber beim zweiten blick
aufgefallen dass es ja gar nicht der
steuerzahler durch einen zusätzlichen
zuschuss bezahlt sondern dass sie den
beitragszahler belasten ohne dass ihm zu
sagen und da hakt da wundere ich mich
schon denn in den letzten acht jahren
haben sie von diesem platz aus uns immer
vorgeworfen wenn die beitragszahlungen
und beitragszahler für renten
verbesserungen aufkommen mussten nicht
der steuerzahler sieht machen es jetzt
genauso herzlich willkommen im club
erfurt
und die lage ist wirklich schlimm denn
sie werden in den nächsten vier jahren
die rücklage der rentenversicherung
komplett plündern fast 40 milliarden
sind jetzt in der rücklage das haben wir
in 16 jahren aufgebaut sorgsam zu
verplempern diese rücklage binnen vier
jahren das ist ihre politik von namen
und es kommt noch schlimmer
sie können nicht nur die rücklage
sondern sie kürzen sogar noch den
steuerzuschuss um eine halbe milliarde
euro pro jahr auch da
klar und sie quasi den rentnerinnen und
rentnern das geld in den nächsten vier
jahren und dann kommen sie mit dem
nachholfaktor fans das ist es liberales
feigenblatt wo sie hält sich rühmen sie
für die generationengerechtigkeit etwas
getan zu haben es bewirkt dass es ein
prozent weniger rentenerhöhung gibt das
sind vier milliarden euro weniger
aber es greift nur für ein ja und dann
ist das ding ein papiertiger warum weil
sie gleichzeitig das rentenniveau auf 48
prozent festlegen und zwar für die
nächsten vier jahre
und diesen wert den erreichen sie schon
ab dem jahr 2023 das heißt dann mit ihr
nachholfaktor einfach ausgesetzt und
insofern
schreiben sie eine rentenreform fest aus
der renten kommission wurde entschieden
des diskutiert den letzten vier jahren
ohne aber über die anderen dinge
renteneintrittsalter
beitragshöhen et cetera steuerzuschuss
zu diskutieren da haben sie sich teuer
etwas erkaufen der fdp was nichts nutzt
das ist wirklich eine versagte politik
und
und auch das eigentliche reformprojekt
des jahres ja schon fast des
jahrhunderts warten ja alle ganz
gespannt nämlich auf die aktien rente
dazu haben sie heute alle irgendwie
nichts gesagt das scheint ja so dass
das phantom des deutschen bundestages zu
sein
ich bin sehr gespannt ob sie das noch
bringen werden aber auch hier habe ich
das gefühl sie haben etwas bestellt und
es ist noch längst nicht ausgeliefert
worden wir werden ihn weiterhin auf die
finger gucken und sind sehr gespannt wie
die beratungen in diesem gesetz
weitergehen dankeschön
kritiker aus der unionsfraktion wartet
auf das stichwort aktien rente da muss
er wahrscheinlich noch ein klein wenig
warten aber johannes vogel aus der
fdp-fraktion der wird hier gleich auch
noch das wort vergleichen und dann nicht
ganz unwahrscheinlich dass er sich dazu
äußert jetzt aber erstmal frank bsirske
der arbeitsmarkt- und sozialpolitischer
sprecher der grünen ist und von 2001 bis
19 verdi vorsitzender war
was mich sehr geehrte damen und herren
von der union
an ihnen wirklich beeindruckt heute ist
ein erstaunliches maß an unbekümmertheit
und selbstvergessenheit
sie stehen für eine politik die darauf
hinausläuft gelaufen wäre wenn es nicht
zu einer stabilisierung des
rentenniveaus kälbern
millionenfach menschen mit altersarmut
zu bedrohen weil sie in die nähe oder
auf grundsicherungsniveau gebracht
werden und damit in eine situation wo
die legitimation der rentenversicherung
massiv bedroht ist wenn man trotzdem
zehnte langer beitragszahlern und
arbeiter nicht mit einer rente rechnen
kann von der man an ständen über die
runden kommt und in würde alt werden
kann wir stehen für eine andere politik
für eine politik dafür sorgt dass nach
jahrzehntelangem beitragszahlung eine
rente erfolgt die dazu reicht ein
stellen über die runden zu kommen und in
würde alt werden zu können das
unterscheidet uns grundsätzlich
mit dem vorliegenden entwurf
nimmt sich die ampel einer der am
meisten armutsgefährdeten gruppen
unserer bevölkerung an am besten sie
denken man meinen ihre eigene politik
besten jahren da gibt es wirklich viel
anders so
mit dem
vorliegenden entwurf
nimmt sich die ampel einheit die am
meisten armutsgefährdeten gruppen
unserer bevölkerung an drei millionen
menschen mit häufig prekäre
einkommenssituation
die weit überdurchschnittlich angewiesen
sind auch grundsicherungs bezug
die benachteiligung der
erwerbsminderungsrente rinnen und
rentner im bestand zu beenden war teil
des grünen wahlprogramms das jetzt nicht
nur aktive erwerbsminderungsrentner
rinnen und rentner sondern auch daran
anschließende altersrenten erfasst
werden ist angemessen und
verhindert einen erneuten teilausschluss
betroffener so wie sie ihn über jahre
praktiziert haben was jetzt vorliegt
was jetzt vorliegt bringt eine
verbesserung von durchschnittlich 50
euro im monat und ist lange überfällig
wir würden es freilich begrüßen
wenn die versorgungslücke der bestands
rentnerinnen und rentner zu denen die
nach 2018 9 zu kommen nicht nur die im
gesetzentwurf vorgesehen zur hälfte
sondern vollständig geschlossen würden
da waren arbeiten wir zurzeit läuft und
ich hoffe sehr dass es uns in der ampel
gelingen wird unsere sozialen
verantwortung so gerecht zu werden wie
dies geboten ist
und ein wermutstropfen ist auch der
zeitpunkt zu dem die verbesserung in
kraft treten soll der erste siebte 2024
das ist in mehr als zwei jahren
der späte zeitpunkt ist operativen
probleme bei der deutschen
rentenversicherung geschuldet die die
umsetzung technisch nicht früher welt
sichtbar machen
freilich freilich
freilich könnten wir dafür sorgen dass
dies nicht frontal zu lasten der
betroffenen geht in dem zuschläge
rückwirkend geleistet werden etwa mit
wirkung ab wir im ersten moment ihren 20
das würde zwar
2026 betone 2026
eine beitragssteigerung um 0,1 prozent
nur wenig machen und einen um quatschen
und steckt dazwischen
und ein um 400 millionen höheren
bundeszuschuss
was aber sehr überschaubar blieben
jedoch für drei millionen menschen eine
wichtige verbesserung bedeuten würde uns
zugleich ein ende der benachteiligung
daran wie ist noch zu ermöglichen
arbeiten hier ich finde wir sind es
diesen weit überproportional von armut
betroffenen menschen schuldig
das gefühl die fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen zum thema rentenanpassung 2022
ist ja eines der felder wo die koalition
spd grüne fdp am meisten gesprächsbedarf
auch untereinander haben nicht so
rednerin ist geriet aus der fdp-fraktion
frühere daimler-manager in und
maßgeblich beteiligt am rentenkonzept
der afg
erhöhung seit 40 jahren und auch die
medien sind begeistert und obwohl wir
diesem gesetz grundsätzlich positiv
gegenüber stehen können wir in diesem
jubel nicht mit einstimmen denn die
rentner haben in den letzten drei
jahrzehnten einen kaufkraftverlust von
über 30 prozent erlitten
von einem leben in würde können viele
von ihnen nur noch träumen
und auch die jetzige rentenanpassung
obwohl nominell hoch kann die
expandierende inflation die grünen
sprechen von sieben bis acht mal höheren
gaspreisen nicht kompensieren ein
weiterer kaufkraftverlust wird die folge
sein wir haben das daher sehr bedauert
dass die regierung in ihren
entlastungspaket die rentner vergessen
hat 300 euro als inflations kompensation
hätten doch noch drin sein müssen
aber der regierung für anderes wichtiger
wir werden daher in kürze einen eigenen
antrag vorlegen in dem wir sie auf
worden diese 300 euro für unsere rentner
noch nachzulegen es ist traurig aber
wahr die deutschen rentner schneiden im
europäischen vergleich sehr schlecht ab
franzose bekommen im schnitt 60 prozent
mehr rente österreicher 80 prozent mehr
niederländer doppelt so viel wie wir und
die schweizer mehr als viermal so viel
und die italiener die von uns über den
coup wiederaufbau also in eu next
generation 50 milliarden euro man ebenso
geschenkt bekommen haben erhalten 60
mehr rente als wir und müssen dafür
sieben jahre weniger arbeiten und da sie
auch noch einige jahre länger leben als
wir können sie ihre renten insgesamt
auch einige jahre länger beziehen
nach eurer stadt sind mittlerweile fast
30 prozent aller über 65 jährigen in
unserem land armutsgefährdet tendenz
steigend denn laut einer auskunft der
bundesregierung von vor zwei jahren
verdienen 15 millionen beschäftigte
nicht genug um im alter eine rente zu
erhalten die über der grundsicherung
liegt
grundsicherung dass es sozialhilfe und
die bekommt auch jeder andere egal aber
gearbeitet hat oder nicht
meine damen und herren dass unsere
rentner wirklich brauchen sind nicht
finanzielle trostpflaster
die immer der entwicklung
hinterherhinken sondern eine
grundlegende rentenreform die diesen
namen auch wirklich verdient
damit wieder gerade gerückt wird was in
den letzten drei jahrzehnten kaputt
gemacht worden ist andernfalls wird
unser land zum armenhaus der alten und
damit das nicht passiert braucht es an
den ganzen strauß von maßnahmen eine der
wichtigsten ist es den niedriglohnsektor
überflüssig zu machen in diesem punkt
stimmen wir mit unseren kollegen von der
spd durchaus überein
denn voraussetzung für gute renten sind
gute löhne dabei muss allerdings
augenmaß bewahrt werden damit unsere
wirtschaft des word bewältigen kann die
ja gerade durch die sanktionspolitik der
ampel vor nahezu unlösbare
aufgaben gestellt wird und natürlich
sind voraussetzung für gute löhne
bestens ausgebildete arbeitskräfte denn
der internationale wettbewerb erlaubt
uns gute löhne nur bei entsprechend
guten leistung und das heißt wir
brauchen wieder schulen die auch
funktionieren aber das meine damen und
herren wird möglich werden wenn die
regieren dann endlich ihre ideologischen
scheuklappen ablegen
gerät die aus der eifel die fraktion die
heute übrigens geburtstag hat nächste
rednerin in der debatte zur
rentenanpassung die 20 22 die kleinen
aus der unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
die erwerbsminderungsrente ist eine
wichtige soziale absicherung denn wer
sie bezieht kann meist aus
gesundheitlichen gründen nicht mehr
arbeiten
krankheit darf kein schicksal sein und
lieber herr kollege kurz das ist weder
links noch rechts es ist das fundament
unserer sozialen marktwirtschaft
und genau deshalb begrüßen wir auch die
vorgesehene erweiterung der
erwerbsminderungsrente die anknüpft
andere regelungen die wir als
unionsgeführte bundesregierung in den
letzten jahren bereits für neuzugänge
geschaffen haben besser wäre natürlich
gewesen sie käme bereits nächstes jahr
und nicht erst 2024 die kritik dazu
kommt ja sogar aus ihren eigenen reihen
auch die wiedereinführung des
nachholfaktor es ist zu begrüßen denn er
ist ein wichtiger beitrag zur
generationengerechtigkeit
nicht im sinne der nachhaltigkeit ist
allerdings die streichung der 500
millionen euro aus dem haushalt eine
sonderzuweisung des bundes die explizit
zur sicherung des rentenniveaus
vorgesehen war
für viele rentnerinnen und rentner sind
die steigerungen im westen 53 prozent
und im osten um 6,1 prozent eine
entlastung zur wahrheit gehört aber auch
dass diese rentensteigerung im alltag
der rentnerinnen und rentner kaum
spürbar sein wird sie gleicht noch nicht
mal die preissteigerung beim einkauf im
supermarkt aus das klang her vermehrt
anwählen und hinzu kommt dass bisher
sämtliche entlastungsmaßnahmen der us
regierung für bestimmte
bevölkerungsgruppen an den rentnerinnen
und rentnern vorbeigehen wir kritisieren
dass ausdrücklich denn wer es mit der
bekämpfung von altersarmut ernst meint
er er spart nicht bei den bedürftigen
rentnern
keine frage im gesetzentwurf finden sich
richtige ansätze am ende des tages sind
es aber
einzelmaßnahmen bei denen in die
richtige richtung gezielt aber nicht
weit genug geworfen wird was fehlt ist
eine grundlegende vorstellung davon wie
altersvorsorge
zukunftsfest gemacht werden kann der
wille zur strukturellen reformen ist
hier nicht erkennbar in den kommenden
jahren werden die baby boomer in rente
gehen laut studien dürfte der zenit der
beschäftigten und damit der
beitragszahler mit 46 millionen im
kommenden jahr erreicht werden man muss
kein mathe genie sein um festzustellen
dass bei gleich bleibend niedriger
geburtenrate perspektivisch immer
weniger junge menschen immer mehr
rentnern gegenüberstehen werden und im
sinne der generationengerechtigkeit
braucht das deshalb ein
zukunftsgerichteten ansatz der alle drei
säulen der altersvorsorge
stärkt
die idee einer kapitalgedeckten
altersvorsorge wäre ein guter erster
schritt gewesen ich kann mich erinnern
dass die liberalen davon mal ganz große
fans wann hier konnte sich aber die
ampel noch nicht einmal dazu durchringt
zehn milliarden euro im haushalt
einzuplanen ein betrag mit dem ein
öffentlicher renten fonds kaum effizient
arbeiten könnte ich muss sagen
eigentlich ist es erschreckend zu sehen
wie wenig gestaltungswillen die ampel
für die zukunft der altersvorsorge zeigt
bleibt nur zu hoffen dass es nicht
irgendwann heißt trennte sich wer kann
vielen dank
und willi klein aus der unionsfraktion
und ihr fraktionskollege kurt egger hat
vorhin schon gefragt wurde ihm das
stichwort aktien rente bleibt wenn es
dafür eine chance gibt dann jetzt der
nächste redner ist johannes vogel aus
der fdp-fraktion rentenexperte seiner
fraktion aber auch erster
parlamentarischer geschäftsführer
liebe
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich freue mich noch einmal eine
sozialpolitische debatte das wort
ergreifen zu können weil ich glaube dass
das wirklich ein
wegweisendes gesetz ist was wir hier
heute auf den weg bringt und das
ist es erstmal ganz offenkundig schon
mit blick auf die zahlen sehr erfreulich
welche rentenerhöhung dadurch ausgelöst
wird für die rentnerinnen und rentner in
diesem land das ist ja keine frage von
politischer willkür sondern wir wenden
hier die rentenformel an aber es führt
dazu dass wir über 5% rentenerhöhungen
leisten und über sechs prozent
rentenerhöhung im osten haben werden ich
sage zwei dinge ganz klar erstens liebe
kolleginnen kollegen von der opposition
das ist wirklich bemerkenswert und das
sieht man schon daran
das ist die höchste rentenerhöhung seit
1983 ist das war das erste jahr eines
arbeitsministers norbert blüm das ist
wirklich historischen eine gute
nachricht für die rentner in diesem land
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und
das ist keine frage für die politiker
dank verdienen weil das haben die
rentnerinnen und rentner verdient weil
rente ist keine sozialleistung sondern
ergibt sich aus deren arbeitsleistung
aber es ist trotzdem eine gute nachricht
und liebe kolleginnen kollegen von der
union max straubinger ich habe mich sehr
gefreut dass ihr den schritt mit der em
rentner gelobt und b als überfällig
markiert hat immerhin ein schritt wohl
selbst matthias birkwald gesagt hat also
was das finanziell auswirkt das sei
immerhin beachtenswert ist meine von den
linken kommen was immer weggelassen hat
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von der
union ist das das wort die das in der
letzten legislaturperiode verhindert
haben ja danke dass ihr lob dass wir
eure politik verändern ziemlich richtig
das zu machen
dass das die rentenerhöhung jetzt so
ausfällt hat übrigens auch damit zu tun
dass wir umfangreich kurzarbeitergeld in
dieser krise genutzt haben das zeigt die
handlungsfähigkeit unseres sozialstaats
in der krise und das ist auch eine gute
nachricht das zeigt aber auch ja dafür
gerne applaus das zeigt aber auch wie
wichtig es ist dass wir auf solide
finanzen achten damit unser sozialstaat
unser staat in der krise unzweifelhaft
handlungsfähig ist liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und das
führt zur bedeutung des nachwuchses denn
das ist in der tat das erste
stabilisierungsgesetz und das erste
stabilisierung cent bei den renten
finanzen seit 15 jahren und das ist
erstens richtig mit blick auf
finanzielle stabilität und das ist
zweitens richtig mit blick auf fairness
weil es dafür sorgt dass die generation
auch in der krise zusammenhalten und
renten und löhne sich im gleichklang
entwickeln und ich will gerne darauf
eingehen was hier für zwischenrufe aus
der union kamen eben auch in der debatte
geäußert wurden also der kollege wicker
und der kollege straubinger die haben
gesagt sie als union hätten dafür die
grundlage gelegt erstens weil die
soziale marktwirtschaft erfunden haben
also liebe kolleginnen kollegen bei
allem respekt nicht alleine sondern das
hat dieses ganze haus in früheren
generationen auf dem weg gebracht liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen vor allem
respekt gegenüber historischen
leistungen der union aber konkret beim
nachholfaktor da ist ja sogar das genaue
gegenteil richtig weil die letzte
legislaturperiode ist ja unter anderem
die union war die nicht bereit war das
thema anzugehen obwohl es offensichtlich
notwendig war es ist diese ampel
koalition die das jetzt auf den weg
bringt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und das ist auch nicht irgendwie ein
zwischenschritt oder etwas derartiges
sondern was hier passiert ist dass die
ausgebliebene rentensenkung
richtigerweise wegen der rentengarantie
komplett in allen im jahr verrechnet
wird dh in einem jahr steht diese
koalition stabilität fairness zwischen
den generationen wieder her das ist die
wahrheit liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
von der union und wenn ihr es nicht
glaubt kann man es ja der süddeutschen
zeitung glauben die haben nämlich am 22
märz diesen jahres bei der vorlage des
gesetzes geschrieben wenn jemand ein
beispiel für politische vernunft und
fairness sucht hier hat er das recht hat
die süddeutsche zeitung liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der union
das heißt die wahrheit ist wir stoßen
hier die tür auf für eine eng geführte
rente und in diesem weg werden wir auch
weitergehen mit weiteren maßnahmen in
den nächsten monaten vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
johannes vogel rentenexperte eben der
fdp fraktion auch mal arbeitsagentur
bereitet in wuppertal vorübergehend
zumindest und wir sind beim vorletzten
redner in dieser aussprache stefan ecke
kommt aus der unionsfraktion dienen und
prägen verlässlichkeit schafft vertrauen
das gilt für alle politischen bereiche
das gilt besonders für die
alterssicherung der menschen die
jahrzehntelang gearbeitet hat muss
darauf vertrauen können von der rente
leben zu können es ist gut dass die
rentnerinnen und rentner in deutschland
an der allgemeinen wohlstandsentwicklung
teilhaben deswegen hat konrad adenauer
1957 die rentenentwicklung an die
lohnentwicklung gekoppelt
65 jahre später gilt das immer noch das
nenne ich verlässliche rentenpolitik die
vertrauen schafft
die union begrüßt daher die vom
bundesminister angekündigte
rentenerhöhung von gut 6 prozent in
ostdeutschland und gut 5% investor stand
auch den pauschalen zuschlag zu den
erwerbsminderungsrenten im bestand
finden wir zunächst einmal richtig
rentensteigerung von mehr als fünf
prozent das klingt auf dem papier gut
die traurige wahrheit ist aber in den
bauch und nächster rentnerinnen und
rentner kommt davon nichts an denn durch
die akute inflation werden die
rentenerhöhungen komplett geschluckt
einem ein plus von fünf bis sechs
prozent stehen folgende preissteigerung
gegenüber heizöl plus 144 superbenzin
bis 42 butter und mehl +17 und gemüse
plus 15 prozent
gerade in inflations und krisenzeiten
müssen die menschen das vertrauen haben
dass politik für sicherheit sorgt dass
sie sich verlässlich an die selbst
gesetzten regeln hält und nicht bloß
nach aktueller kassenlage entscheidend
mit den verschiedenen staatsleistungen
sofort zuschlag für kinder
einmalzahlungen und die energiepreis
pauschale versucht die ampel regierung
den preisschock für die bevölkerung
abzumildern
wer gute politik für die menschen machen
will muss diese krisen leistung im
zusammenhang mit unseren heutigen
unserer heutigen rentendebatte sehen sie
schließen die rentnerinnen und rentner
ganz bewusst von diesen leistungen aus
sie lassen die im regen stehen von den
sozialverbänden haben die dafür am
montag in der sachverständigenanhörung
zu recht viel kritik bekommen und in
dasselbe horn stoßen die herren fascher
und hüter und erstaunliche harmonie
es ist traurig dass man nun geneigt ist
den rentnerinnen und rentner nahezulegen
einen umgekehrten enkeltrick anzuwenden
wenn zum beispiel der oma einmal im jahr
für eine stunde auf seine enkelin
aufpasst und dafür von seiner tochter 12
euro mindestlohn im rahmen eines
minijobs oder aus selbständiger
tätigkeit bekommt dann hat er auch
anspruch auf die energiepreis pauschale
glauben sie dass man so vertrauen der
rentnerinnen und rentner gewinnen kann
behaltet ist offen die waren in unserer
nordrhein- westfälische sozialminister
karl josef laumann er fordert in seiner
bundesratsinitiative den empfängern von
alters und erwerbsminderungsrente die
energiepreis pauschale direkt mit den
renten auszuzahlen
wehrheim
bringen sie es war das herz gerade
denjenigen jetzt nicht zu helfen die es
am nötigsten brauchen die aktuellen
preissteigerungen sind besonders für
einkommensschwache haushalte
existenzgefährdend besonders in den
blick nehmen müssten sie gerade jetzt
die menschen die in verdeckter
altersarmut leben menschen die ansprüche
auf grundsicherung im alter haben diese
aber aus ganz unterschiedlichen gründen
leider oft aus scham nicht in anspruch
nehmen und das sind viele also stoppen
sie das ampel gehampel diskutieren sie
angemessen die probleme im zusammenhang
sorgen sie krisen politisch für eine
gerechte beteiligung der rentnerinnen
und rentner an den allgemeinen
entlastung und spielen sie
ordnungspolitisch nicht weiter auf zeit
kümmern sie sich endlich um eine
grundsätzliche reform der
alterssicherung die altersarmut
verhindert
gerade in der krise müssen die menschen
der politik vertrauen können verspielen
sie dieses vertrauen nicht leichtfertig
vielen dank
nächste rednerin für die spd-fraktion
tanja machalet
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
heute ist freitag der dreizehnte und der
erzeugt er bei vielen menschen immer so
ein bisschen mulmiges gefühl und bei
einigen kollegen kollegen aus dem aus
der cdu hat man auch das den eindruck
dass sie heute morgen so ein bisschen im
falschen fuß aufgestanden sind
aber ich muss sagen bei mir erzeugt der
tag heute und wirklich gutes gefühl denn
ich kann sagen wir halten das was wir
versprechen
mit dem vorliegenden gesetzentwurf zur
rentenanpassung beginnen wir damit das
was wir zur verbesserung bei der rente
versprochen und im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart haben umzusetzen und das ist
oft gezogen
ich möchte als es auch nochmal auf die
erwerbsminderungsrente eingehen denn das
was wir hiermit umsätze ist wirklich
längst überfällig und es war um es noch
einmal deutlich zu sagen in den in der
vergangenen qualifikation nicht machbar
und ist das dürfen sie und das brauchen
sie jetzt auch hier an dieser stelle
nicht zu leugnen
ich freue mich wirklich sehr dass wir
mit diesem gesetz nun die situation von
rund 303 millionen menschen zumindest
etwas verbessern können auf die details
wurde in der debatte ja schon intensiv
eingegangen und man kann sagen wir haben
einen wirklich guten gesetzentwurf aus
dem ministerium erhalten dafür und dafür
dass wir die verbesserung so schnell auf
den weg bringen können bin ich wirklich
dankbar und
dennoch wer auch ich und das hat der
kollege gern ist auch schon deutlich
gemacht dass es durchaus noch luft nach
oben gibt daran arbeiten wir daran
arbeite ich daran arbeitet meine
fraktion und zweitens wir
setzen den nachholfaktor vorzeitig
wieder einen auch darauf ist bereits an
vielen stellen hingewiesen worden
darüber ist schon intensiv diskutiert
worden mit dem wir ausgefallene
rentenkürzungen in den voll in die
folgejahre nachziehen so steht es im
koalitionsvertrag und so werden wir es
machen daran halten wir uns
dass wir nicht die treibende kraft
hinter diesem vorhaben waren das ist nun
wirklich kein geheimnis
dennoch sehen auch hier dass die
vorzeitige reaktivierung des nach und
faktors uns langfristig gesehen
natürlich bei der finanzierung der
gesetzlichen rente helfen wird dabei ist
sehr wichtig und es muss auch hier
gesagt werden der nachholfaktor darf nur
soweit angewandt werden dass das
rentenniveau nicht unter 48 prozent
sinkt und ich möchte auch noch mal
darauf hinweisen dass der nachholfaktor
oder
nachhaltigkeitsfaktor den wir auch hier
mit kletten nicht zu verwechseln sind
das ist in der tat alles sei technisch
lieber kollege burgwald und wenn ich das
jetzt hier ausführlich erläutern würde
würde das die zeit springen mir ist
nämlich wichtig auch noch mal was zum
dritten punkt zur rentenerhöhung zu
sagen und ich finde es auch noch einmal
deutlich sagen das ist die größte
rentenerhöhung seit fast 40 jahren in
westdeutschland mit 5,35 prozent
im osten sind es sogar 6,1 12 prozent
und das ist in dieser zeit so dringend
notwendig und das lassen wir uns auch
von niemandem hier kleinreden und
ich will auch noch mal darauf hinweisen
dass das alles nur möglich geworden ist
weil wir eben mit dem kurzarbeitergeld
den arbeitsmarkt stabil halten konnten
und ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern
dass es frau merkel oder die cdu war die
beim thema kurzarbeit die treibende
kraft waren dass er unser bundesminister
hubertus heil und die spd
und ja auch wir diskutieren jetzt schon
darüber wie wir rentnerinnen und rentner
in einem möglichen weiteren
entlastungspaket berücksichtigen können
auf der auf die entlastungen die mit den
bestehenden paketen intendiert sind auch
für renten rentner ist
bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil
schon ausführlich eingegangen und das
müssen sie auch einfach zur kenntnis
nehmen aber nochmal zu erklärt zur
erhöhung zurück die führt dazu dass ist
ein ganz wichtiger aspekt dass der
rentenwert in denen nun zugegebenermaßen
nicht mehr ganz neuen bundesländern ab
diesem jahr 98,6 prozent des wert in den
alten bundesländern beträgt das heißt
bald haben wir endlich die anpassung
geschafft und wir müssen nicht mehr
differenzieren was ist ein enorm
wichtiger schritt für die weitere
einheit
mit dieser guten botschaft liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen in diesen
schwierigen zeiten wünsche ich ihnen und
uns allen einen guten nachhauseweg ein
schönes wochenende
nächste woche sametime same place ich
freue mich auf die weiteren beratungen
im ausschuss herzlichen dank
tanja machalet war die letzte rednerin
in dieser ersten beratung des
gesetzentwurfs der bundesregierung zur
rentenanpassung 20 22 ist betrifft die
empfänger gesetzlichen rente aber es
betrifft auch die empfänger von
erwerbsminderungsrente auch da soll es
verbesserte leistungen geben in zukunft
es wird weiter diskutiert werden im
ausschuss für arbeit und soziales und
dann werden wir das gesetz den gesetzen
zur abschließenden beratung bald
wiedersehen und wiederhören